[Musica]
sapete qual è il principale problema per
l'imprenditore italiano
fallire
e sapete qual è il principale vanto per
un imprenditore americano
fallire avere fallito
e rialzati dopo il fallimento
perché questa differenza tra l'america e
l'italia perché in italia il fallimento
è visto come un marchio d'infamia un
evento indelebile un ostacolo
insormontabile
e cere e far restare il fallito dentro i
propri limiti dentro i propri confini
mentre negli stati uniti hai visto come
un evento per rinascere e quindi per
superare i propri limiti e per diventare
parafrasando il tema di oggi potremmo
dire al limite
le risposte in realtà
c'è ed è nella storia ma prima di
rispondere alle domande che vi opposto
vorrei raccontarvi due storie la prima è
la storia di un giovane imprenditore
americano che non ancora ventenne fonda
la prima azienda la propria azienda che
commercializzava computer
non ha successo e l'azienda fallisce
ma non si dà per vinto a fondo una
seconda azienda con il suo migliore
amico che creava computer con processore
intel
e anche questa impresa fallisce non si
dà ancora per vinto e passa dal
dall'hardware al software e finalmente
ha successo
sapete di chi sto parlando
di bill gates l'uomo più ricco del mondo
in fasi alterne con jeff bezos e
creatore della microsoft
non male per un fallito
la seconda storia un po più triste è la
storia di un imprenditore italiano non
famoso come bellezza un imprenditore che
ho conosciuto per motivi professionali
il quale negli anni 80 fonda la propria
impresa
con 6 milioni di lire l'impresa cresce
diventa
un'impresa di successo con 1.200
dipendenti più di 350 milioni di euro il
fatturato questo imprenditore ha
osannato
dalla gente
diventa un personaggio pubblico
ha molti amici molto seguito molti
educatori
purtroppo arriva la crisi del 2008 il
suo gruppo si trova ha sviluppato in una
spirale di crisi per uscirne fare degli
errori e un giorno tornando da dubai e
all'aeroporto di malpensa viene
arrestato e portato in carcere
a san vittore nel famigerato sesto
raggio divide la cella di qualche metro
quadro con due delinquenti comuni due
spacciatori ci resta a 3 mesi
e quando esce nel frattempo la sua
azienda è fallita
gli amici rivolta alle spalle si
separano
perde tutto e si sente un fallito e
viene considerato un fallito un reietto
dalla da quelli che prima lo osannavano
la sua storia però non finisce qui
la fine ve la racconto dopo e prima
cerco di rispondere alle domande che mio
posto all'inizio perché in italia
c'è questa concezione negativa del
fallimento come vi accennavo prima in
realtà le origini siano nella storia nel
medioevo dove
il fallimento è un istituto creato dei
mercanti per tutelare la buona fede
negli affari
chi non paga i propri debiti tradisce la
fiducia dei propri creditori
e quindi veniva imprigionato veniva
bandito da società civile veniva posto
molto spesso in braghe di tela cioè un
paio di mutandoni leggeri ed esposto al
pubblico ludibrio
e per esempio qui siamo a mestre vicino
c'è venezia venezia c'è
andava in voga la figura della vittima
la vittima era un signore vestito di
rosso che inseguiva il debitore
e gli diceva ricordati che devi pagare
ricordati che devi pagare tutto il
giorno abbastanza estenuante direi però
credo che anche a noi ogni tanto farebbe
comodo avere una vittima per
inseguire i nostri debitori ma non è
possibile
il pisa questa concezione negativa del
fallimento se perpretata nei secoli fino
a giungere ai giorni nostri
e laddove il
fallimento di una persona spesso si
confonde col fallimento
dell'oggetto cioè il fallimento
dell'azienda si confonde col falli già
col fallimento dell'imprenditore quindi
spesso non fallisce un imprenditore ma
fallisce l'azienda e si dice che quelle
imprenditoriali fallito e l'imprenditore
viene e spunto dal mondo
del non solo del dell'economia ma anche
dalla società civile nel senso viene
considerato un reietto
perché è così diversa quasi come se
fosse un virus quasi un covo di 19
perché in america è così diversa la
concezione del fallimento
in america in realtà
l'america è un paese che si fonda su un
principio il principio del fresh start
del nuovo inizio
america un paese fondato da immigrati
immigrati
i primi pellegrini del my flower che
fuggivano dalle persecuzioni religiose
in europa
gli irlandesi che fuggivano dalle
carestie gli italiani che fuggiva dalla
povertà
gli ebrei che fuggivano dal nazismo
ecco tutti fuggiva da qualcosa dunque
avevano se volete avevano fallito nella
loro vita precedente cercavo una nuova
vita offre start appunto tanto che
ancora oggi gli imprenditori e successo
americani quando narrano le loro le loro
storie di successo partono dai loro
fallimenti ostentano i loro fallimenti a
differenza di un imprenditore italiano
che nasconde se ha avuto dei fallimenti
nella sua vita
ma tutti abbiamo avuto di fallimenti
alzi la mano chi di voi una volta non ha
mai fallito almeno una volta nella vita
sia non solo nella parte professionale
ma anche nella parte personale
d'altrone fallire deriva da fallere che
vuol dire cadere inciampare
capita a tutti di cadere o inciampare
almeno una volta nella vita
ecco in america il concetto di fresh
start si accompagna un altro il concetto
molto interessante che il concetto di
fail fast giorni fast
fallisci velocemente per imparare
velocemente
è più importante un insuccesso elaborato
da un successo rapido e superficiale
tanto che nella silicon valley che è il
centro dell'innovazione tenete presente
che il tasso di insuccesso di un'azienda
del 90 per cento
solo che lì
memore di questi principi
i giovani start upper dopo i loro
fallimenti si rialzano e ripartono più
entusiasti di prima più forti di prima
cosciente dei propri errori
quindi
qual è qual è il messaggio che vi voglio
lasciare oggi
da questo talk che vi vorrei lasciare
oggi un messaggio in realtà
never give in
lo disse churchill molti anni fa un
famoso discorso non mollare mai
perché noi siamo abituati a concepire il
fallimento come
una porta che si chiude
e si fosse una finestra che si apre il
fallimento non è o meglio non è solo la
fine di un qualcosa
il fallimento è l'inizio di
qualcos'altro
se lo vogliamo ovviamente e se ci
giochiamo le maniche e l'inizio di una
nuova avventura di una nuova ricerca
anche di noi stessi
che di fronte alla caduta di fronte al
fallimento abbiamo due opportunità
la prima rimanere per terra e lamentarci
dei nostri problemi della nostra
sfortuna del fato avverso la seconda
possibilità è di rialzarsi
più forti determinati di prima cosa per
veri e propri errori e combattere
ecco probabilmente consapevole di questo
insegnamento
o forse anche inconsapevole forse anche
inconsciamente adesso vi racconto la la
fine della storia
dell'imprenditore di cui vicenda vo
prima l'imprenditore che è stato in
prigione che ha avuto delle disavventure
in realtà
l'imprenditore è
affondato una nuova azienda
si è imboccata le maniche non si è dato
per vinto
ha fondato un'azienda attiva nel settore
del commercio di import di prodotti
dalla cina i prodotti sanitari e l'anno
scorso nel pieno della crisi mondiale
ha sfruttato diciamo questa crisi e la
sua azienda la sua nuova azienda hanno
avuto un boom di fatturato con un utile
post tasse pagate le tasse di 2 milioni
di euro non male per un fallito di rai e
quindi vi lascio con questo
potremmo dire con questo suggerimento a
voi e me stesso
a tutti capita di cadere e quindi quando
cadiamo
ringraziamo di essere caduti rialziamoci
facendo tesoro dei nostri errori
più forti e determinati di prima
never give in grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]